you
are they still following this yes is
there one of them hmm you looking at us
yeah does he have just one hand on the
steering wheel mhm when you hear
something that sounds like a gunshot
drive
nicely done
we recently discovered the existence of
an international criminal organization
with ties to foreign axis rumor has it
Liz bills an atom bomb we have no choice
but to work to get them to infiltrate
this organization will leave you two to
get acquainted
Napoleon sold this year is most
effective ages
KGB the youngest man to join in their
best within three years America is
teaming up with things could get a
little messy the thing is I work better
alone I work better alone too okay i'll
let you tag along how did you get the
invitation to my party I stole it Ferris
seat I hope you're wearing laughs
sometimes just never when I'm stealing
this not very good at this whole subtly
pengantar you it'll be like this for 20
minutes Kim touch I'll make me put you
over my feet Russell let's hit it shall
we
No
a special agent you aren't having a very
special day are you you were these
belong to you or to me
you